youtube star boxer and now professional  wrestler logan paul appeared at wwe  summerslam over the weekend going viral  for his electric frog splash body slam  despite having success in the wwe paul  doesn't plan on giving up his love for  boxing appearing on the pat mcafee show  sweaty and in boxing attire paul shared  that there are plans for him to return  to the ring for the first time since  facing floyd mayweather in june of 2021  that's why i was late i was sparring i'm  a boxer again we're getting back in the  ring we're going to go from professional  sport to professional sport i want to  get a fight in december when asked about  any potential opponents paul deferred to  keep that information to himself i have  some people in mind but i can't say you  know you only get one first impression  that's part of my ability to make  moments i like making first impressions  big so i want to wait until we're ready